[Musica]
anemone abbia parte le palle volevo
dirvi che oggi finalmente facciamo
qualcosa di sensato ho finalmente deciso
questa luce che madonna bene dimetto che
meglio ha deciso di fare un file
risponde un po diverso stavolta l'ho
deciso di rispondere a domande scomode
perché fa più click
insomma e io faccio il mio business mi
avete mandato un sacco di messaggi su in
direct su instagram che ce li ho tutti
qua e le fiori anzi prima monetizziamo
di più pubblicità bambini bambine siste
pronti a passare una scuola da urlo
allora e comprate lo zaino di barigelli
tutte novità 20 prodotti per la scuola
tutti per te sai anche non c'entro
assolutamente niente il drive ma borsa
per la palestra uno struzzo di nuovo al
cui migliore di modi 62 traffico per
azioni
comprato di mamma papà comprami lo zaino
di famigerati diventano bambini bambine
non gli è bastato lo zaino di favi j
beh c'è pure il trolley per le nostre
vacanze alle cinque terre o comunque di
porta in uscita nel 2018
chiedete a mamma e papà di comprarvi
trolley diva dj così anche all'aeroporto
sapranno riconoscere il vostro youtuber
preferito vi è stata quella donna e fai
capire chi sei
ho la più pallida idea di che cosa mi
abbiate scritto però viva la vita non ho
paura di inter fatevi sotto
elisa mi chiede hai mai avuto amici
barra fidanzate che ti hanno sfruttato
per quello che si è diventato non lo so
se i miei amici lo sono i miei amici per
questo fosse pietro se per ogni altro in
uso non lo so
giulia mi chiede vuoi un figlio adesso
voi nessuno adesso fammi finire il blog
se potessi rivivere un solo giorno della
tua vita passata quale sarebbe ci chiede
ludovica alle ora se dovessi vivere un
giorno nella mia vita passata se dovesse
sceglierlo probabilmente il giorno dopo
la maturità è un po come quando finisci
la tua serie tv preferita no
che poi non sai più cosa fare della tua
vita 10mo come si respira ecco quando
finita la maturità più o meno mi sentivo
così però in positivo nel senso adesso
non scaricare il dlc come funziona non
lo so dalila a quanti anni hai perso la
verginità
[Musica]
sedici nomi come domanda di già da
quando è l'ultima volta che hai pianto
di fronte a un'altra persona e da solo
da solo non mi ricordo probabilmente
stava guardando un film si sono un po
checa quando guardo i film bianco quando
il pianto tutti volta di fronte alla
persona e va una persona che io mi
ricordi la mia ex
c'eravamo lasciati non me ne frega un
cazzo in realtà era solo perché l'avevo
lasciato in casa dei videogiochi che non
potevo più recuperati maria quante
banane servono per essere sazi far da se
provengono da me a te ne basta uno
bianca quali stata la volta in cui sei
stato freddo nato in un porco demoni non
so leggere quale è stata la volta in cui
sia stato freddato in maniera peggiore
non sono mai stato funzionato giuro
veramente ma perché io non chiedo alle
donne le donne chiedono a me ilaria ci
chiede ti manca giocare a the happiness
festa è veramente scorno caterina hai
mai mentito ai tuoi genitori riguardo un
brutto voto
ogni tanto li ricevo quelli veri perché
ogni tanto prendevo la sufficienza ma
molto raramente costruisco il set questa
è una mia fan page cosa fai con i regali
dei fan che non puoi tenere ma allora io
a casa mia torino o un
garage gigantesco non avevano né gigante
perché adesso pieno di roba dei fan
insomma le cose che non riesco a tenere
tutte quante nel in casa perché è
impossibile
sono lì roberta a quanti anni la prima
volta ma vi interessa così tanto perché
rebecca descrivi in quattro parole la
tua ex carta di credito bloccata maria
mi chiede come ti vedi da qui a 10 anni
10 anni più vecchio era scontata come la
morte ma così chiara ho notato che
maschio me la fa una domanda ogni tanto
ho notato che anche tu sei un fan del
signore degli anelli chi preferisci tra
legolas e aragorn non vedo dove sia la
scomodità di questa domanda comunque
regola chiara mi chiede ti manca vivere
a torino no però mi devo cucinare io
perché io da solo quello mi manca un
sacco perché la mia mamma è più brava di
me a cucinare e anche a lavarmi i
vestiti perché io non so stirare c'è una
volta ci ho provato e non lo si fa c'è
nel senso ha bruciato il pompiere vale
domanda di giada quando senti la canzone
per band di elektra ti metti a cercare
non ho mai sentito la canzone per te non
ci tengo però grazie domanda seria
quando verrai a fare un raduno a catania
quando non metterete la canzone per te
di sottofondo andiamo avanti
la domanda che cos'è star a silvia se
dopo un rapporto sul family friendly non
posso dire una parola ma l'avete capita
ci si fa una lavanda con la coca cola è
vero che non si rimane incinta dalla mia
ampia esperienza ti dico che devo
chiedere a piedi ciao l'ora e riesce a
guardare questo video
[Musica]
anche io ogni tanto mi cristo sulle
gengive per divertimento qual è la cosa
che ti mette più a disagio che ogni
tanto fanno i tuoi fan durante vite
indirizzo ogni tanto qualcuno qualcuno
almeno quello cerca di limon armi e io
cerco di quale è tratto caratteriale
ammiri e rispetti di più nelle persone
che anche presentata sono un deficiente
ti chiami laura grazie aver fatto quella
prima domanda quale tratti caratteriali
rispetti di più nelle persone quando
stanno zitte apprezzi ciccio merlino ci
chiede a lorenzo questa è la mia domanda
mi pensi mai quando ti parlano di amore
perché io ti amo anche io ci sediamo e
soprattutto io quando faccio l'amore ti
penso spesso perché so che tu c'hai
lungo il naso di brutto e quindi il tuo
naso mi fa sentire un uomo penso al tuo
naso molto spesso preferiresti vivere il
resto della tua vita in america o in
giappone è difficile rispondere a questa
domanda perché sono due paesi che non
c'entra una mazza l'uno dall'altro in
giappone sicuramente in giappone perché
allora innanzitutto l'america dopo un po
mi in austria non so perché dovrei
andarci per capirlo è un po strana
l'america sono tutti dei bambinoni
mentre in giappone funziona tutto da dio
bella la natura in giappone giappone
tuttavia ho finalmente una domanda
decente che si discosta dall'argomento
chiara mi chiede ti piacerebbe avere la
patata
così almeno i più family friendly bella
domanda no c'è
no non credo no anche questa devo
chiedere la pietra che la domanda di
nicolas sedile degli autobus più scomodo
di così c'è poco effettivamente c'era
già alessia mi chiede bombe resti ariana
grande o la tua ex prof di matera mia ex
prof animate aveva 75 anni quindi
come ray pietro piuttosto sfide che non
metti due stephen quanto rimorchi solo
col tuo nome ci stai provando con una no
clara chi preferisci tra stefano e suri
questo è scomoda veramente ah beh
dipende dalle situazioni registrare non
so se questa è una bella domanda vorrei
essere sincero ma non lo so perché
allora con entrambi o un problema
guadagniamo in giro e vacanza loro
spendono la madonna investiti e io che
sono cioè il braccino corpo come
dinosauri t rex
in poche parole sono un cerchio quindi
non spendo una sega e soffre chi dei due
vuole fargli spendere di più e suri
quindi forse stefano in questo caso solo
perché sul rivale farmi spendere di
breve sta non ho una preferenza sono
simpatici entrambi alessia ciao l'ho
rivisto la tua riservatezza riguardante
la tua vita privata come cambierebbe la
tua vita con l'arrivo di un figlio
inaspettato vediamo questo blog in
fretta ragazzi giovanni quando torna
happy wheels tornerà quando mette bizet
saranno alti quanto me se potessi
uccidere chiunque in questo mondo senza
prigione o altre punizioni chi sarebbe
la tua prima vittima
no in realtà nessuno perché mi state
tutti i simpatici giovanni come fa la
colla a non rimanere attaccata al
tubetto
ma lo sai che io questa cosa me la sono
sempre chiesta sempre da piccolo anche
adesso come quelle domande tipo come fa
l'acqua del cesso ogni volta che la tiri
a ritornare su non lo so non l'ho mai
capito se avete la risposta a questa
domanda mi farebbe molto piacere non lo
so bravo che l'hai chiesto
sei un ragazzo intelligente farai strada
probabilmente se il futuro bill gates e
alla pesca o tè al limone lo so che c'è
una guerra in atto su cosa sia meglio io
preferisco alla pesca hai un'idea di
come morirai in rete io credo che
mourinho nudo
non so perché ci sta secondo me io un
bel poster morirò nudo se tu sei vestito
male e mori poi arrivi paradiso in quei
vestiti poi mai presenta piuttosto nudi
e meglio penelope e mi chiede se i
scomodo ora no perché io ho sempre
questa posizione molto comoda perché mi
permette di avere più sangue al cervello
così all 80 per cento di intelligenza in
più rispetto a uno che sta seduto
normale sarà mi chiede ci hai mai
provato con la tipa di qualcun altro no
perché fortunatamente mia mamma non è
manuela mi chiede sei mai stato sospeso
da scuola
no per una volta hanno convocato i miei
genitori perché avevo scritto sul
computer
abbasso berlusconi però una roba del
genere non so perché l'avevo scritto
però mi hanno convocato i genitori
qual è stata la tua prima celebrity la
tua prima celebrity crush sono riuscito
a dirlo miley cyrus e lo è
non lo è ancora per niente farà una
volta lo era cene secondo era miley il
hannah montana
quindi ragazzi dire che possiamo
concludere qua visto che c'è questa
erano più o meno scomode non siete stati
così tanto cattivi mi immaginavo altro
però dov'è
ragazzi io spero che video vi sia
piaciuto sono contentissimo di
registrare questi video la mattina
mentre devo il mio te perché comunque
rilassante fare i falli risponde a me
piace sempre quindi ne arriverà un altro
molto presto a te poi un'occhiata in st
granfondo metto la storia fatemi delle
domande stay tune ed iscrivetevi al
canale e schiacciate la campanella che
c'è sotto perché dà un sacco di
notifiche sui video che escono quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
senso è un mi piace anche vari social
come descrizione se una sera quali siti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vedo bene grazie
[Musica]